another hong kong media outlet is
shutting down in the face of growing
pressure from the chinese government
citizen news said it no longer felt safe
to publish after journalists from a
competitor were charged with sedition
the decision by one of the territories
few remaining independent news providers
came on the same day that a new
legislative council loyal to beijing was
sworn in
[Music]
for hong kong this is the start of a new
era
these are the first lawmakers to take
office under new election rules that
excluded anyone deemed disloyal to
china's communist government
and the first to be sworn in under
china's national emblem
another sign of beijing's tightening
grip
just 20 were directly elected with voter
turnout the lower since the city
returned to chinese rule
hong kong's chief executive carrie lam
oversaw the ceremony she now faces even
less dissent from outside the council as
well
after a major independent news website
announced its closure amid a media
crackdown
we've been trying our best not to
violate any laws but we can no longer
see clearly the reasoning of law
enforcement
the move was prompted by a police raid
on pro-democracy outlet stand news last
week when several journalists were
arrested under colonial era sedition law
to many western observers citizen news's
closure is just the latest sign of hong
kong's increasingly unfree media
environment
and of how rapidly beijing has worked to
erode the city's special status and
freedoms
well let's talk about that with our
correspondent phoebe kong
citizen news declared it could no longer
report without fear
what does
the news media have to fear
well the top editors of citizens news
today they told the press that
explicitly
that the closure of citizen news was
the decision was triggered by the
closure of another pro-democracy news
outlet stan news just a few days ago
after police raided the newsroom
they sent deployed over 200 offices to
search the homes of the of the editors
at the found the top management and also
the the editorial office and um the
police also the frozen 61 million hong
kong dollars of stan news and prosecuted
the top editors for publishing seditious
publications so that particular case has
triggered a wiring chaining effect in
the hong kong journalistic industry
including citizen news so that's why
they decided to close the media outlet
before they were exposed to a further
risk under the national security law and
also other offenses
which was
enacted during the colonial era but now
being reused by the authorities to
target political dissents so this is the
main fear of citizens news and they have
said that
even the top editors were
very veteran journalists who have worked
in the industry for decades they can't
ensure the safety of the staff so that's
why they have to make this decision so
phoebe what then is the state of free
independent reporting in hong kong
following this closure
our citizen news established in just
2017
it was
an independent news outlet mainly
financed by subscription fees of the
breeders it was independently around
like without pressure from the business
people or political pressure um so um
citizens new and also stan news which
was um shut down earlier last week um
both of them
have gained a huge popularity in hong
kong
even though they're just a very young
media outlets in hong kong with just a
few years history but um they're really
popular they have a large reader base
with millions of readers in hong kong
especially
those pro-democracy supporters so um
this is indeed a really huge blow to the
uh journalists industry that two
independent media outlets have to close
themselves um like um
so after
under the pressure of the authorities
and the new legislation that they have
to adjust to the new normal in hong kong
that um the media environment and the
freedoms are shrinking are set by the
attitudes and management of the two news
outlets and so just only within six
months apple daddy and the two um online
media have shut down so now um
we can say like most of the influential
independent media outlets have shut down
with only a few remaining
outlets due running so um this is really
like affect the um the future of hong
kong so the future of
how journalists can work on the ground
lastly phoebe i mentioned the
swearing-in of the new deputies of the
legislative council the election in
december was controversial the
candidates were tested for their
political loyalty to china
what course will the legislative body
now take
uh well this is um today is the first
day when the lawmakers and 99 lawmakers
met uh in the parliament um indeed we we
have seen a kind of like harmony within
this among themselves because um 89 of
them are pro-beijing figures with only
one of the lawmakers claimed himself as
non-pro-establishment
um so um this is uh
resulted like in this kind of situation
because um a new vetting mechanism was
introduced to the electoral system and
leading to the absence to of the major
opposition came so we no longer see any
opposition lawmaker inside parliament
and
the lawmakers the probation lawmakers
have already
stressed that they will
cooperate with the authorities in terms
of many issues including the enactment
of further national security related uh
offenses and uh legislation so this is
some of the agendas that we are
expecting that will
further affect the whole political
landscape in hong kong
dw correspondent phoebe kong thank you